السؤال الان ما هي العقبات والتحديات التي
تواجه كاف وحلفائها فيما يتعلق بمقاتلات
افسته عشر فالتحديات اللوجستيه تكمن في
انك قد لا تتمتع بالسيطره الكامله على
مجالها رغم ان انظمه الدفاع المضاده
للطائرات التي تمتلكها تمنع الطائرات
المقاتله الروسيه من القيام بعمليات خارج
خط المواجهه هناك تحدي اخر وهو انخفاض
مخزونات الاسلحه الغربيه ولاسيما الاسلحه
المضاده للطائرات بالاضافه الى الخدمات
اللوجستيه المكلفه رغم ان قدمت وعودا
لواشنطن بعدم استخدام اف 16 داخل العمق
الروسي لكن لا تزال المخاوف من تصعيد
محتمل قائمه في حال لجات كاب لهذه الخطوه
وينظر لهذه الصفقه المحتمله على انه قد
تسهم في قلب الموازين حيث ستقدم لكاز لكاز
ميزه تنويع المهام الجويه وفرض السيطره
على الاجواء بالاضافه الى حمايه المشاه
على الارض في هجماتها المضاده كما ستعمل
الطائرات كنظام واحد مدمج مع الدفاع الجوي
الارضي ما يسمح لك باسقاط الصواريخ
الروسيه التي تستهدف بها موسكو المنشات
الحيويه الاوكرانيه
لدي ادله قاطعه بانهم لن يستخدموا اف 16
للمضي قدما والانتقال الى الاراضي الروسيه
لكن اينما كانت القوه الروسيه داخل
اوكرانيا والمنطقه سيستطيعون القيام بذلك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب
للاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات